m vous allez rester avec nous parce
qu'on voudrait vous présenter un
reportage maintenant d'alain vernon sur
une nouvelle chaussure
vous savez les chaussures rivage crois
que vous connaissez par excès le c'est
le must en la matière de football et ils
viennent d'inventer une chaussure de
football donc où le laçage ne se fait
plus sur le devant mais sur le côté il
paraît que c'est très efficace pour
marquer les buteurs platini qui est un
grand spécialiste va nous commenter
cette invention mais d'abord vernon et
la présence cette chaussure n'est pas un
gag les joueurs de l'équipe de valence
siège de lusine l'on essayé la
révolution c'est donc qu'on ne lasse
plus la chaussure sur le coup pied mais
sur les côtes
en réalité le plus important dans une
chaussure de foot c'est la souplesse de
son cuir - le contact du pied avec le
ballon et rugueux plus le joueur
retrouve précision et adresse d'ailleurs
l'extérieur du soulier la partie la
moins utilisée au football on frappe
dessus on amortit de l'intérieur du pied
alors le lacet écartés pourquoi pas
après tout le lacet a très mauvaise
réputation pense que tous les buts qui
ont été ratées avec les lacets ne sont
pas chauffées à ses deux chaussures
magiques alors une chaussure magique
peut-être mais en tout cas certainement
très technique voilà donc une chaussure
qui a un look c'est évident elle séduira
sans doute plus d'un joueur reste à
savoir si en match elle maintiendra
correctement le quai c'est ce que l'on
demande après tout une chaussure qui
coûte au moins 400 francs voilà aille
bien michel platini vous avez entendu
les commentaires et la présentation de
cette chaussure quel est votre avis mon
avis je pense qu'il faut avoir des bons
pieds pour marquer des buts et pas
forcément des belles chaussures première
chose deuxièmement je crois qu'on
devrait surtout aller au niveau du côté
du côté des enfants qui n'arrivent pas à
lacer leurs chaussures
alors si on trouve un système pour
empêcher les enfants qui ont cinq ou six
ans où ces temps de jouer au football et
de ne pas lacer leurs chaussures ça
serait encore très bien